une prise de pouvoir par la force qui a
braqué les yeux du monde entier sur la
birmanie le 1er février l'armée renverse
la chef du gouvernement de facto
en somme tout y pour justifier son geste
le commandant en chef de l'armée birmane
dénonce des fraudes électorales lors du
scrutin de novembre dernier qui avait
renforcé le pouvoir donne sound succi
l'armée birmane a demandé à la
commission électorale au parlement et au
président conformément à la constitution
de 2008 de proposer des solutions pour
les listes électorales ils ont manqué à
leur devoir à tous les niveaux l'armée
birmane a agi conformément à la loi pour
trouver une solution par le dialogue
jusqu'à la dernière minute si l'armée
est au pouvoir le peuple est quant à lui
dans la rue ce samedi constituaient la
huitième journée de manifestations
consécutives malgré le couvre-feu imposé
de 20h à 4h du matin ainsi que
l'interdiction de manifester instaurée
depuis lundi dernier la mobilisation
massive s'intensifie jour après jour
avec pour symbole de ces protestations
le salut à trois doigts main tendue vers
le ciel
cette contestation populaire a pour seul
mot d'ordre le retour de la démocratie
en birmanie
nous faisons confiance à notre
génération z on fera ce qu'on peut avec
notre énergie et notre force pour
combattre la dictature militaire
cette nouvelle est dans nos pensées tous
les jours on se réveille avec cette
terrible nouvelle et on est très
contrarié
on va se battre tous les jours jusqu'à
ce que le peuple reprenne le pouvoir
[Musique]
de son côté l'armée réprime les
manifestations massives dans la capitale
et dans le reste du pays les canons à
eau sont régulièrement utilisés pour
disperser les protestataires
tout comme des tirs de balles en
caoutchouc mais également des tirs à
balles réelles depuis le coup de force
du 1er février plus de 350 responsables
politiques représentant de l'état
militants et acteurs de la société
civile ont été placés en détention selon
l'onu la communauté internationale se
mobilise contre les militaires birmans
au pouvoir les etats-unis ont annoncé
gelé 1 milliard de dollars d'avoirs
bénéficiant à la junte
les nations unies demande quant à elle
des sanctions ciblées contre les
responsables militaires impliqués enfin
le conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'onu exige le retour de la démocratie
et la libération immédiate d'aung san
suu kyi
mais il ya quelque chose que le peuple
birman craint encore plus c'est d'être
forcé à vivre de nouveau dans les
ténèbres imposé par un pouvoir brutal et
répressif membres du conseil des droits
de l'homme le message que le peuple
birman vous adressent à tous et aux
peuples du monde est clair cela ne peut
pas durer
le peuple birman et la communauté
internationale accentue donc la pression
sur la junte militaire au pouvoir
l'armée qui a ordonné dès son arrivée à
la tête du pays
la mise en place de l'état d'urgence
pour une durée d'un an